this is Piers Morgan on Sensei coming up
Revelation from Ronaldo football's
biggest superstar gives his blistering
verdict on life of Manchester United
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored welcome to the special
edition of Piers Morgan on Center cinema
next hour Cristiano Ronaldo turns up the
heat his sensationally reveals he has no
respect for his current manager he calls
out Manchester United's owners the
glazers he talks candidly about his
future at Old Trafford and the World Cup
and Qatar he even reveals his retirement
plans and what do you think sibling or
messy but I begin with a very personal
question
yeah do you have more pounds in the bank
or more Instagram followers
it's a good question probably similar I
don't know
probably similar uh I'm just trying to
work out how Wayne Rooney could hate you
even more and probably that's the answer
well not only him imagine the rest of
the rats they're gonna criticize you too
but it's good it's good to be still
number one if you you see the make
something that make me happy too if you
see Forbes Magazine every year I'm in
the top of the list so it's not by
coincidence too but knowing you I don't
it's not the money so much it's just you
want to be at the top right I mean
that's what I think what drives you
someone said to me what drives Cristiano
Ronaldo I don't think it's money I think
it's being the best
beating people it's a competitive Street
the the records the adrenaline but
Pierce let's let's let's be uh honest
the last years the football change
I see football now as a business to be
honest
sometimes the Georgian have expression
that I don't understand they treat you
they treat you players like a piece of
meat and say yes you say everything is
true when they want you when they they
they they count with you they give you
everything when they don't they try to
to make a hard life to you
I see football piece the last years as a
business I saw many many things that I'm
disappointing the passion for the game
is still intact but in the same way I
say I saw other things as well
which is this surprise me but in the
same way it's part of the business
because
if you see the world how it is in the
moment it's it's all business everyone
take on itself everyone they are more
individual well you become a commodity
where if you can sell record number of
shirts in 24 hours great right but if
suddenly the team isn't performing well
they need someone to blame it looks to
me like at Manchester United the default
position is it's got to be Cristiano's
fault exactly it's always always my
fault the problem is always me I look
like I'm the black sheep which is I
don't like if you do it good or if you
do bad they all is going to find some
some criticize even in the national team
the last three months as I told you
before the criticize was so bad I mean
not only in football way but
professional
and family way as well which surprised
me a lot
looked like I was a bad guy which is not
true people have to listen
from my mouth the real the facts as well
this is why I give this interview
because I thought I I think it's the the
right time to speak out of my my mind
which is what they say the last four or
five months is completely garbage I'm
not gonna say 100 but 99 it was garbage
people say false things are alive things
which things have annoyed you the most
family issues
um well I want to talk about one in
particular on that which is when you
were late back for the pre-season
training a lot of speculation because
you'd said several weeks before that you
wanted to play Champions League football
and that you were maybe looking for
another option because it didn't look
like United would get to play Let's make
my points for example the preseason
moment and after you mentioned and
new clubs or interesting for example the
preseason I had a very very bad
which is I don't say nobody the people
who surround me they saw friends and
even my mom I had some problems in
vacation that my young daughter they
have a little problem they have brown
kids which is systems bronchitis yes yes
your little baby yes I was in Majorca
and holidays and sister one week in
hospital
which is was
you know you don't enjoy a lot and after
what had happened so well exactly and
the people make make up histories that
they say that I don't want to go travel
because they people have to understand
that I'm a human being I'm always going
to be in my side of my family
I'm not negotiate nothing behind that
you understand
and I even have the the letters of from
the hospital the the feedback of the
health of Bella which is I'm not sure
nobody nobody asked me I have I keep for
me people forget that I'm human human
being that I passed through a difficult
moments
well you must have been worried sick I
mean you I was very worried I was very
baby son and now your baby daughter's in
hospital exactly and you must have been
absolutely directive of
and the president of Manchester United
and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never this ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for the football never
now or
10 years
behind or forward and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Jill we had one week in
hospital because the Bell have a big
problem
and I didn't go to the preseasons
because of that because I didn't I
didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do it the Precision because I think
it wasn't not fair to left my family for
a preseason this is why I didn't go
I mean that would if my employer didn't
believe a story like that that would
I would be so angry
because everyone I'm not mentioned only
in that in that
Manchester way but in a world especially
in a football world
they are very very very individual
everyone everyone everyone
look for on selves or themselves
they don't care about
your moments your struggle moments your
issues family problems
they want you they want you doesn't
matter
your family problems I don't mean
Manchester but in a general
as I told you before the football goes
so fast you have many competitions many
games pre-season World Cup now listen we
have last you have one game after three
four days you have to be in the national
team preparation for the World Cup it's
hard sometimes you have to sell
everything and you know
be with your family
take the best decisions and
in this summer I didn't feel comfortable
I feel uncomfortable the way they treat
me especially the the Press they doubt
about me the professional that I am
it's impossible to be 21 in the top of
the game if you're not professional they
doubt about me which is make me feel
very very very sad because in my life
I'm always one of the best professional
this is why I'm still playing that level
you play in a pre-season friendly and
you leave the ground early with several
other players and there's another huge
fuss about this
what was the truth about that had you
got permission to go do you wish you
hadn't left early now Chen Hong wasn't
happy it was reported what's the truth
because um I'll I will be honest with
you
um
is something that I regret to left from
the stadium probably or maybe no I don't
know it's difficult to
tell you 100 percent
if I'm
but let's say I regret
but in the same way I felt provoked by
the coach I'm not allowed for me
a coach to put me in three minutes in
the game Sorry I'm not that kind of
player I know what I can give to the
teams you're talking about the Tottenham
thing the Tottenham yeah I'm talking
about in pre-season it was a friendly
where you left the ground with several
millions and eight players right so that
they mention only my name yeah which is
his
everyone do that
I don't understand why they mentioned
only about about high value kind of play
a game
last year many players do the same in
that game eight players do it the same
so but they only speak about the black
Chip which is me which is I completely
understand okay it's done I apologize to
the coach and for me
the chapter was was closed
claims he's being forced out of
Manchester United
foreign
[Music]
wanted to show you who the boss was
he dropped you he benched you
he mucked you around
he talked about you in the Press
were you getting that feeling I mean did
you feel that the feeling he always
mentioned to me that I didn't need the
Precision so I should wait for my
opportunity I really understand I should
well okay I understand
but I'm not gonna give you
points but
you don't do it the same for sediment
from to every players I'm not going to
mention players but they don't do it the
same way
second I understand that
becoming a new job Manchester was so bad
the last five years that it should make
they should clean the house let's say in
that way
but the way they approach the way the
Press make this so big it's because
probably the
the communication wasn't the best
uh but I I really understand in the
beginning because I didn't do the
pre-season I don't start to play but
going more farther than that further
than that other things happened that
people they don't know
and I'm not I'm not uh hiding that the
empathy with the coach is not good I'm
I'm honest you don't have a good
relationship with him I'm not mean good
relationship the empathy is not it's not
good let's say you think he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve
but
it is what it is this is why probably
the the game against Tottenham well I've
only come to these two games so against
Manchester City where United got
destroyed
he didn't bring you up
you brought other Strikers but didn't
bring you on and
I felt insulted on your behalf I was
like surely against Manchester City if
you're losing this badly and you've got
the greatest player of all time sitting
there you at least give him some time
don't you but he didn't and he said
afterwards the reason was he had too
much respect for he wanted to respect
you when you heard him say that what did
you think
excuses
I say as excuses
I sell many things that
I don't wanna I don't want to criticize
him it can it can have different opinion
than me that they choose the players
that I think is better for the team I
respect that but the excuses all the
time you know the excuses have short
legs you cannot excuse all the time
which is things that don't make sense
okay you don't put me against Manchester
City because of respect of your career
and you want to put me three minutes
against daughter well that's the thing
so then you then play Tottenham don't
make sense and then he wants to bring
you on with three minutes to go which is
the complete opposite to what he said
the situation was with City I think it
did it did it did purpose because for
example in the national team the other
clubs if the coach want to put me five
minutes if someone injured or or if they
really need me I will help but in that
way I felt provoked not only because of
that game but before he was deliberately
provoking him right for everyone
everyone know that disrespecting you
think exactly this is why I say I don't
have respect for him because they don't
show me respect for me this is why
we we are we are in that situation I
have to be I have to be honest that the
things don't going well because of that
because the empathy don't exists and it
keeps it keeps say things for the Press
but the Press
say what they think it's it's it's good
to protect probably him and Manchester
United but
as I know as I understand many things
that is signed three years contract with
Manchester United probably I'm not going
to be too much longer in Manchester
United apart when I'm finished my
contract I really understand but I like
guys that they don't like they speak
honest they're being throttle frontal
and I'm not in a good negotiate my
morals my morals always will be intact
and what what's going in my in my in my
things the last two months was not
respect in many ways
which is it I can regret for example
against Tottenham to left the stadium
before the Finish Well there's a video
clip which appears to show ten heart
telling you to get ready to come on and
you gesticulate back to him I'm not
going to do that and as a result you get
suspended for the next couple of games
and he goes public and says it's because
you refuse to come on and you did then
issue a statement of some regret saying
you know you're a professional and
you've never been suspended before I
don't think now entire career I mean
when you look back at that I guess my
question would be you've always been
very acutely aware of Your Role Model
status around the world
do you wish with hindsight you hadn't
done that and handled it I regret to
left the stadium yeah but I was as I
told appears before I didn't felt that
he had a respect for me to put me on
three minutes after the issues that we
had before
um
I was very very very very disappointing
for
the communicate of Manchester United to
be honest I never had a problem with any
club with any coach
and they suspending three days which is
I felt a lot and it was
and and level of sport clubs I felt a
lot and it was a shame is it humiliating
I think so yes I have to to say the
truth what I felt I remember I arrived I
I arrived
well I don't want to say I don't want to
say details what it pretend to do it but
I'm not going to say that but I remember
arriving home and Christiana see me that
did you not go to the game and say no
because
the club punished me with three days and
he did like
oh they're gonna punish you if you are
the best player in the world and uh
you're not gonna play say no I'm not
gonna play because I I'm not being I'm
behave and you look at me like my daddy
not behave what
in one way I was
good because I was like more relaxed but
in the same way I feel very disappointed
because
okay I regret I apologize I'm not
perfect I commit a mistake but to
suspending three games three days
for that I think it's too much and they
they make fire for the Press which is
really disappointment and that seems to
have been the pattern of the way ten
Hargis wanted to treat you since he
became manager just constant
attempt to disrespect you I guess
many many points happen
I think in some certain points I think
was strategy
from the club for me to react like that
because they wanted you to leave
probably yes they're trying to force you
out not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I should don't say that
I don't know but listen I I don't care
I'm always people should listen the
truth yes I feel betrayed and I felt
that some people that don't want me here
not only
this year but last year too
they didn't want you to go there at all
no really yes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh
sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion do you ever talk to them the
glazes never never not since you've gone
back no they give all the power to the
president the sport directive
a lot of Manchester United fans
are very negative about the glazes they
think they're taking all the money out
and are spending enough on players on
the infrastructure issues he talked
about do you think the fans are right
the fans are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
I want the best of the club this is why
you're coming to Manchester United this
is why I love this club
but you have some
things inside the club which is don't
help
to Manchester reach the top level as
City Liverpool and even now Arsenal for
example
which is complicated it's difficult
um
it's hard in my opinion it will be hard
for Manchester to be in the top of the
game
the next two three years the Glazer
stays on it I'm not mean the glazes but
the structure this structure
um as as Picasso say you have to destroy
it to rebuild and if they can start from
me I'm
for me is not a problem I'm all is what
I'm gonna say I love Manchester United I
love defense they're always on my side
but if they want to do it different era
different generation they have to change
many many things
when you walked away at Spurs and didn't
go on Gary Neville said your behavior
was unacceptable called for you to be
punished he said he knows what he's
doing he's experienced and players of
that power have a real negative impact
when they do it the influence they have
on other players is really negative
and it was after that you gave them the
old blank treatment which was very funny
by the way
um
but for Neville to say that about you
they can't they can't they only they
don't see the big picture
why I react like that what's happened
all the behind the scenes all the behind
the scenes I was
probably not provoke
they will accept to play three minutes
after all situations that going through
the last two months
don't tell me that top players the guys
want everything the key players
will play three minutes come on this
isn't acceptable after what
they keep saying before that they
respect me they do this they do that
for me it wasn't not respect this is why
I take this decision I regret I've
I apologize to my teammates for this
situation I did a post
and Instagram I regret to left from the
stadium
I regret my teammates they know what I
felt I said to them apologize but in the
same way I'm not regret to take the
decisions to done coming on I'm like
that I will be always like that if you
don't have respect for me I'm not going
to have respect for you and the coach
didn't have respect for me so this is
why
the relationship it's it's in that way
and it keeps saying in the press that he
can't with me like me but it's only for
the Press really yes 100
so where are you now in your head with
all this because the World Cup is about
to start you're going to go there with
Portugal and we'll talk about that in a
moment with a very exciting team
actually
um but where are you with the United
they won't be playing again now until
after Christmas that leaves a few days
before the January transfer window do
you think you'll still be a United
player come January 1st it's difficult
to tell her right now because we my
moods is right now
to the World Cup it's probably my last
World Cup of course my fifth World Cup
I don't know what's going to happen
um
after the World Cup but as I told you
before and I will say again
the funds will be always in my heart and
I hope they
've been in my side
even if I'm back or if I'm not back or
if I stay or whatever
nobody's perfect episodes in the life we
all have uh is part of
the human beings is part of me to be a
human being and father as well
I always will commit a mistakes
uh uh but I don't know it's hard to tell
you right now what's going to happen the
World Cup because my focus is only for
the World Cup for the Portugal national
team
coming next well Ronaldo still be Old
Trafford after the World Cup I'll ask
him
[Music]
if you had your time again knowing what
was going to happen
would you sign for Manchester United
again
as I told in the beginning I'm always
took my decisions by
not
emotional moments but maybe this
this decision I took by emotional
I'm not regret
because I took with 100 conscience
but it was more emotional than rational
I don't know if it's no sense
uh but it was good was good because
I was happy
when they left me be happy
so I tried to give my advices my
experience
to help Manchester United to be where
they deserve to be
um
I don't pretend to be more smart than
the other ones nobody is smarter than me
but I'm not smarter than nobody
when I arrived in Manchester United I
always be available to help the team to
do the good things to put in the right
spots
to compete with the best teams
but it's hard when they they cut your
legs and they don't like you to shine
and they don't listen your advices I
think I I have Awards to advice to the
club because the trophies that I won
individual and Collective I think I can
help a lot but when the infrastructure
is not
good what's amazing is you ended last
season
with hat tricks you're scoring hat
tricks for fun one against Tottenham
you know you were playing great football
but you were starting most games and now
this season you've barely started any
game something happened you know I'd
imagine you're a bit like a racehorse
right if you don't start I didn't do
depressed season right right is there is
the excuse right which is the preseason
so you think if you've been able to just
do what you did last season you just got
carried on scoring for sure you think I
I just learned
to score goals maybe I'm not motivated
that I'm supposed to be probably as I
told you before because I'm human being
I feel the things
I'm not perfect
but my motivation is not the same that I
was that I was
a few months ago
and I hope to change do you feel like
you need a fresh challenge
I'm not saying if it's fresh fresh
challenge but let's say let's say I'm
not I cannot answer right now because my
focus is for the World Cup
but I don't know maybe it's good for
Manchester and berries and probably is
good for me as well
to have a new chapter probably but I
don't know if if I will be back I will
be the same Cristiano but I hope people
being on my side and let me shine like I
did
all the clubs and all ears what is the
truth about other clubs making offers
for you some people have said there were
no offers at all I happened to know that
there was a gigantic one from Saudi
Arabia for example 350 million euros for
two seasons is that okay yes it's true
that's a staggering sum of money yes
which you turned out in that moment yes
I mean that to me says you're not just
about the money this is what it's what
I'm going to mention now it's they see
many many garbage thing that
if you are Urgent what you're going to
do you go the clubs but George Mendes
for example have more than 100 players
and they go Chelsea they go Arsenal they
always mention Cristiano Ronaldo they
offer Cristiano base let's be honest
who's the most expensive player salary
player that
Premier League have in history it's me
even with 37 years old why they're gonna
even they even offer me to sporting uh
Annapolis I will be honest with you you
don't I didn't have many many clubs but
I have many many offers of the other
clubs which is I didn't change because I
didn't plan to do it but I have but what
the Press keeping say and the garbage
price say that nobody want me which is
completely wrong
and I was happy here to be honest I was
motivated to do it a great season here
but but they continue to repeat nobody
won Cristiano how how they don't want a
player last year's got 32 goals
with national teams I mean that's the
point I don't get because there are
people out there and you see them you
hear them
and they say well he's not the player he
used to be as if somehow at 37 you're
going to be as good as you were at 21.
anyway everyone changed but you are the
greatest 37 year old anyone's ever seen
right and you're still extremely fit so
it just seems to me nothing's changed
from the player I saw banging in hat
tricks last season except that you have
a coach who doesn't want to start you a
few months or what they're going to
change there's nothing
because I feel like you can still be a
top player but for me it's it's it's
it's stupid questions when people say ah
they are not the same nobody is the same
day by day we're getting old every one
of us you understand it's normal you
have to adapt and I think nobody in this
game
have this brain that adapts with his age
I'm not I'm not want to be cocky to say
that I'm the same that when I asked 20
of course no but I'm adapt and I be
smart to know my strength what I'm good
to do and I'm still playing that level
and I score goals and I will continue to
score goals if my mind is clear and
happy and if the people surround me
there help me to be successful player
especially the coach president
directives but when you feel that the
energy don't go surround you it's
difficult you to be yourself which is
happening this is what's happened with
me but what they say the last three
months is completely garbage and wrong
they say that I offer me this and that
and many presidents and directives speak
about their reject from it's completely
lie they'll lie because he's is is not
what's happened I had many clubs not
many a few clubs that they want me to
sign and I didn't go because I feel
comfortable here this is the true how
easy is it to turn down 350 million
pounds to kick a football for two years
in Saudi Arabia it's hard it's hard it's
hard but in the same way I I thought
that I was very happy here that I still
capable to score goals and make people
up is it also that you want to keep
playing at the highest level that you
want to play Champions League Football
you want to keep breaking records is it
again it comes back to my gut feeling
about you that if it was just about
money you would be you'd be in Saudi
Arabia right earning this king's Ransom
but you that's not what motivates you
you want to keep exactly because I
thought I I still believe that I can't
score many many goals and helped the
team because I I still believe that I'm
I'm still good and capable
to help national team even Manchester
United but if you don't feel surrounded
that the energies is then in your side
it's difficult of course the criticize
we're gonna exist all the time all right
37 is still not the same but I want to
see if some guy of my heads maintained
the level that I that I show you're not
gonna teach me that nobody gonna teach
me that I know he was fit as you've ever
been do you think yes yes in this moment
I feel very very good I believe that I'm
gonna do it Amazing World Cup
and prepare physically and mentally
but
Pierce is it it is what it is life is
good I'm good my mental is good I'm
happy to do this entire video I know
they're going to generate very polemic
of course but Christianity they would
anyway right I mean they've all had
their say and now you're entitled to
have your say and you know better than
anybody because you are Cristiano they
criticize me when I don't speak of
course when I'm going to speak according
to criticize me even more but it's
something that I can I can deal with
that I know I'm gonna disappointing a
few people maybe I'm gonna make up a few
people but
it is what it is the life is it's
completely
difficult we have obstacles in our lives
and uh
I will keep running to fight against the
people who don't believe me and the life
is a challenge and I wanted people the
people that they are wrong when they say
that if you do leave United and I accept
this is not a done decision either way
but if you do and it seems to me like
that's more likely than not as we sit
here
what would your message be to Manchester
United fans who've had to
read all this stuff all year and
probably have a very mixed idea about
where the truth lies what would you say
to them if you do end up leaving
it's hard it's hard for me to say that I
will not be back to Manchester United
but regardless as you say it's it's
let's see what's going to happen
but as I told you before the fans for me
always will be in my side will be always
in my heart I see during the days when I
go to the street to love the passion
that people have for me
um the respect
I hope that they never forget
the things that I will continue to do it
not only in the past but in the present
too Manchester will be always in my side
defense will be always in my side
doesn't matter what's going to happen
and I appreciate the loves that they
send for me all the time even when I'm
done play and we even when they when
they criticize me they always will be in
my heart so thank you to Dollar supports
hope to see you soon and uh they always
will be in my heart
and what about Ceramics the man who
persuaded you to come back again
really like a father figure to you
really in many ways like another another
father to you
what's his
take on everything that's been happening
what's his opinion of all this
I don't speak with him like one month
ago but it's always on my side you
always understand me he knows that he
knows better than nobody that the club
is not on the path that deserves to be
he knows everyone knows the people who
don't see that is because they don't
want to see they are blame
the fans
they are always
the answer
and the passion for the game Manchester
belonged to defense but they should know
the true the infrastructure they are not
good they should change if not
Manchester is not going to be where
there used to be what when Sir Alex
Ferguson David Gill was and how to be
part if they count with me to help the
club
to be successful if not the life will
continue I will continue to my journey I
will continue to make fans happy and
score goals and do it tricks and
everything and
um it's good it's part of my journey
[Music]
thanks Ronaldo
[Music]
I want to just talk to you briefly about
the World Cup
um your fifth World Cup when you say
it's your last but I mean you'd only be
41 at the next one could we have a sixth
World Cup potentially will be tough will
be tough so this may be the last one
probably yes you've got an exciting team
full of experience and young players
Portugal are you optimistic about your
very optimistic we have a fantastic
coach we have a good generation of
football players
I'm looking forward that we're going to
do an amazing world cup would that be
for you the the Pinnacle of your career
to win a world cup with Portugal face I
don't know I don't
I never well I dream one time about that
holding the World Cup yes
gonna be tough extremely difficult but
everything is possible but
of course we're gonna compete it's hard
to beat who are the who are the biggest
Rivals we are not the favorites
no of course but who do you weren't
famous when you won the exactly exactly
who do you think are the ones to really
watch who are the best squads out there
probably France
France
I will put Spain Argentina Germany
Brazil Brazil of course they look good
to me they look good what about you
haven't mentioned them oh England as
well yeah yeah of course England you
think England have a have a chance I
have a chance beside Portugal in my
opinion
uh
but let's see will be different
will be in a winter is it weird playing
at winter it's UK do you care
don't really care to be honest a part of
the issue is that the country wherever
they try to
to they try to speak now that it wasn't
not good option to do there but they
should do that before we should focus
only in football the competition to
people to enjoy do you think all the
politics and the morality debates and
stuff should that all be left aside now
100 focus on the on the games I feel
that of course they should though they
should do that that debate should be had
before you award exactly exactly they
should concentrate it in in all
competition all the national teams the
people to be welcome in a in a in Qatar
and I I see I see a good tournament to
be honest I think Qatar they are
prepared they are prepared for that and
we'll be where to play in the beginning
of the Season yes but in the same way a
challenge I think it's to be honest it's
good I feel good I feel with good energy
so what about this idea you get to the
final
Portugal the Argentina
you scored two Messi scores two
the last minute 94th minute
you score a third for your hat trick and
you win the World Cup is that be honest
still good is that the dream it's too
good I didn't expect that two good
dreams but if it happened
ah come on you see
that's true you can scale you can score
another player I don't care I don't care
if the Portugal being a final in score
even the goalkeeper I will be the most
happy man in the world but if if this
happened come on
I will say I will finish football if
this happened
all right yeah
100
I mean it may well be Messi's last World
Cup
he's never won it either I mean you are
you know you're linked forever the pair
of you to me the greatest there's ever
been
you're number one for me uh thank you
he's number two you're number one to you
he's number two
um but it's an amazing relationship you
have even though you're not I know great
friends or anything but you're always
respectful when you see each other what
do you think of him Messina as you both
head to maybe your last work as a
football player yeah and as a person
amazing player is Magic top
as a person we share the state
16 years imagine 16 years
we are the highest we share so I have
great relationship with him I'm not
friend of him in terms of what I mean
friend is the guy who is with you in
your house or speaking of phone no but
it's like a teammate he's a guy that I
really respect the way he always speak
about me
even his wife or my wife my girlfriend
they always respect and they're from
Argentina my girlfriend is from
Argentina so good what I'm gonna say
about Mexico great things he's a good
guy is you do everything for football
the best player you've ever seen
excluding yourself
probably yes
um
zidane probably
yes that I
play fight with him yes have you ever
had dinner together never would you like
to why not one day to sit down and yes
listen I I like it can I come I love of
course I love to meet people I love
people you know I like I love to share
things ideas learn things ideas new
histories New Brains why not
I will do it for sure I will do it that
would be in a few years yeah at the bats
as Maradona and Pele did yes
no problem come on I'm a good person I
know I've I have a good heart and you
know I'm
I don't like I don't like to you know to
criticize people it's not the way I I
took my life everything is positive and
it's like a weird sequence of events and
bappa goes to Real Madrid and PSG ring
you up and go we've had a great idea we
want to put Messi and Ronaldo everything
it's everything it's possible in in in
football so and that would be incredible
why not I don't know I don't know as I
told you before they sell some shirts
for sure for sure for sure they will
sell a lot of shirts we're also going to
win the Premier League I hope so you do
mind yourself first if not if not
Arsenal is some team that I like to see
to play did you write the team at the
moment yes I do I like the team I like
the coach I think they do it a good team
and uh if Manchester United don't win
the Premier League I will be happy if
Arsenal do what would you like your
legacy to be Chris John I mean well let
me ask you first do you have any plans
to retire I mean how long do you think
you can keep playing football I want to
play two years more three years more two
three years my Maximo I want to play
with
want to finish with 40. I think will be
a 40 40.
a good age but I don't know I don't know
the future sometimes you plan you plan
one thing for your life and as I told
many times the life is the dynamic and
you never know what's going to happen
Tom Brady in America the great NFL
quarterback retired
then he has a conversation with you on
the Old Trafford pitch and whatever you
said to him I'm psychology so the next
day he comes out of retirement
psychology see I'm good psychologist
what did you say no I thought I thought
it took the decision a few weeks before
uh but it was good what did you talk
about you two guys speak about in
general is very very smart guy uh he
knows a lot about football we have a
nice conversation and he's got a hat
trick that does it yes I did he gave me
good energy when I have good and good
energy and you have another goat in the
stadium because they're fire you up
exactly yeah thing right yes yes it's
energies it's all about energy when you
are when you have good energy around you
I can be interesting things
what about Jordan Peterson who I know
came to see you amazing man yeah because
I've interviewed him a few times and he
was fascinated to meet you and to talk
to you both about private things about
what had happened to your family this
year but also about professionally you
and your situation
I'm a huge fan of him I I read his book
12 rules
and I felt that is really really
interesting guy and I love to meet smart
people and uh fantastic man and I
learned a lot some advices that he gave
me
he gave you
we have a nice strategic conversation
not only for the moment of my life I
mean not only for football because my
life is not resume only for football I
have I'm a businessman I've you know and
many important things on my life and
when you are surrounded with these
people for with you as well people that
make your life more interesting they
reach something in your daily life I
appreciate because
is that kind of people that thinking
outside the box which is I I appreciate
and we had a nice conversation strategic
conversation not only for the moment but
for the future as well it gave him some
points that I never expect but
the beginning was to meet him a good
person an intelligent person and uh was
fantastic and I we keep in touch I speak
with him it's good
you're going to do Cristiano Ronaldo's
12 rules to life why not for the future
maybe more rules exactly for the future
probably I wanna I wanna educate it I
want educate it not only my family but
my fans as you know I have a lot
millions of fans probably for the future
I want to do it some book but not the
type of book I've got a good idea for
you on that yeah I told you it's a good
one but to help people how to be
how to maintain longevity and also I
think in your case how to survive life
right it's a lot of people out there who
are struggling to just deal with life
and the one thing you do better than
anybody I've seen in sport
is resilience
mental strength right that's what it's
really I think it's the most important
thing and I can see me in the future of
course I'm I want to improve my English
it's very good it's much better even
than last time I interviewed yeah but I
have to improve I have to do more
interviews I have to improve I know and
I'm I'm I I I want to improve
and I see myself to do it when I'm
retired to speak from
millions of people
advices yeah how to be a professional
player how to maintain your longevity
how
I'm not psychology but I passed through
many many things and I can you know
about this above all how to win how to
win which is the most important I think
it's what it's all about I have
experienced to
to expire people
for that I think I'm I'm a role model
and I I can help many many people in
that way if they want my help I want to
listen to it right for sure especially
the young people I want to be with the
young people to speak with them not only
for them but for the Fathers as well to
put him in a in the right spot
Cristiano what a pleasure thank you very
much indeed thank you very much peace
very pleasure for me thank you thank you
very much
thank you
Andy with a wink of course it did an
extraordinary interview with an
extraordinary footballer and an
extraordinary man did he change your
mind that's for you to decide one
thing's for sure he set the record
straight and he was most definitely
uncensored
foreign
[Music]